il va lancer une procédure de divorce
ils font d'ailleurs que ce soit les
britanniques qui envoie une lettre non
pas au père noël mais européen que ça
ira pour activer l'article 5 du sixième
prime oeuvre tarder à l'envoyer surtout
si cameron dit que ça sera peut-être son
successeur qui va qui va faire ça après
le congrès des conservateurs le meilleur
hommage que pour des raisons domestiques
comme pour des raisons européenne il
faudrait quand même passer à l'action
du point de vue britannique parce que
quand on lance une procédure de divorce
même dans la vie courante on sait bien
et que le jugement va intervenir après
quelques temps parfois il faut quand
même qu'ils aient des changements
concrets ne sait pas on fait chambre à
part éventuellement en tout cas on
déménage enfin on ne fait pas comme
avant je ne peux imaginer que le peuple
britannique qui a gagné 52 48 c'est
quand même pas tout le peuple contre
toutes les élites à yap à 48% des
littoraux royaume uni va exiger de voir
des changements concrets rapidement
réduisions vis de l'union européenne il
ya le respect évidemment de ce verdict
l'union européenne ce n'est pas l'union
soviétique c'est pas une prison des
peuples
les britanniques veulent sortir enfin de
la dore mais faudrait pas non plus que
ça prenne cinq ou huit ans parce qu'il
ya d'autres choses à faire qui ces bus
qui sont bien plusieurs gens qui
débutent vraiment dans notre voisinage à
traiter absolument